so fun fact about Jared
um Jared's going to all have us listen
to what he puts his children to sleep in
so that is going to be his walkout music
so we'll all say hello to Jared so so as
the title says here we are going to see
if we can build an r package with an llm
they're all the rage right now so we are
going to first ask it to help us write
some functions just get the functions
written then we are going to ask it to
produce documentation and then we're
going to actually have get help building
the package
so first up we will ask the question you
are all I guess the prompt you are an
experienced R programmer write a
function whose input is a path to a
folder and the output is a count of each
of the different file types in the
folder
now notice what it gave me I didn't say
to use base R it just used base r
and it does Camel case it just did count
because I didn't say it didn't know that
I like camel case it did it
the one thing I don't really like is
that opening curly braces on the
function definition line I prefer it on
its own line but I could live with that
and it's really cool it actually checks
first that the path exists before it
actually calls any code on it to get
information this is a nice clean error
to come out of there
if we call the function we get back the
results we expected notice it is the
names above the results that's because
it is a named Vector that's very base r
but I ask can you rebuild it with an
argument that lets us specify which file
types to consider
and it's really smart it will actually
first check to make sure I gave an
argument a value to the argument because
if I don't provide a value and it just
looks for certain file types that will
be an error so it's really smart it's
doing a lot of error capturing and
preventing errors I should say that's
really really awesome that it's doing
that
and I run the function both by itself to
prove that the default case works and I
do it using an argument saying just look
at csvs and jsons and it performed as
expected so so far so good
but now the question we've all been
waiting for
can you rewrite it to use the Tidy verse
so I had to remove blank lines so it
would fit on the slide so just keep that
in mind but otherwise the first thing I
noticed is that it is both loading the
packages like fs and it's saying FS
colon colon dur LS and it's kind of
weird to do both you do one or the other
typically
but that's okay and it's cool that
instead of list.files it's now using dur
LS that's nice
it's using map which is great but notice
it's using the old Anonymous syntax it's
not using the new Anonymous syntax it's
still using the old one
and it's still using the Meg gritter
pipe which maybe is cover backwards
compatibility but I like using the new
pipe but you know those are little
details and I love that it's giving
comments now the comments are saying
what it's doing now why it's doing it
but still amazing to get comments I'm
very happy
using the function now we get the same
results but it comes back as a tibble
because it's tidy which we expect
then I give it the prompt if you're
going to use package colon colon
function then you don't need to load the
packages at the beginning
and it got rid of them but notice very
carefully I just said package package
colon colon function I didn't say which
ones to get rid of I didn't say which
packages which functions it just
realized to get rid of all the library
calls because it was already doing per
colon colon map Etc and that's great I
didn't have to be very specific I was
very generic in fact and I figured out
all the spots that needed it
and not only that it gave me a couple of
messages explaining why this is a good
idea
it mentioned the conflicts and mentioned
how it's more explicit so I was you know
a lot of good feedback from the from the
llm
but then I noticed something that you
are listing all the files when keeping
the file names we want if we specified
Andy I said can you change it so that
when listing file type files we only
search for the specified file types of
any so rather than searching for all the
files and then reducing them just search
for fewer files to begin with
so first it does a check here and again
it only does it if I specified an
argument which is a good safety check
but then it is mapping over each of the
different file types and calling dir LS
for each type of file
it would be a lot better if it used a
regex to do the search be a lot cleaner
so I said I said instead of using permap
use a regex and feed that to glob
pattern
and that'll be better
and so it made the change and that's
good because you know I bet I'm more
familiar with regex
on today let's keep saying here yeah
sorry it nope we're good we're good I
said feed the regex to The Blob and then
it gave me a note saying that using a
regex instead of per is more elegant
where did it learn that is that getting
it from stack Overflow saying there's a
more elegant solution
whatever it did I'm very happy came up
with that result
but then when I ran the code it didn't
work
so I had to dig into the code and maybe
I should have been inspecting the code
to make sure things were right
or maybe what I should have done in
hindsight is I should have told GPT hey
this isn't working can you figure out
why it's not working I didn't try that I
wish I did
but I told her return zero results and I
told I think that the glob pattern is
wrong and that instead you should use
the regex argument instead of the glob
argument so I told it to do two things
fix the pattern and I told it to uh you
switch the argument and it did both of
them and it even explained why the regex
was better and it explained the regex
itself including why I had to use two
backslashes to escape the period it's
great having a regex Whisperer because
regex is tough right
so now it works as specified so great
so let's take another step farther can
you write the oxygen documentation for
this function
and it did it
I prefer when you actually explicitly
say at title in that description but
this is more standard so it didn't and
it even used don't run because it knows
the examples won't work on Cran
we all know how fun that is when your
examples don't work on crayon they're
very nice about it
it explained don't run and that's great
because that's obscure not everyone
knows don't run so it's really great
that it explained it in a note I would
have preferred that a wrap that don't
run inside a don't show but hey it's
pretty great to begin with
so then I said
make a similar function that calculates
the number of lines for each function
and notice that's a typo I meant to say
the number of lines of each file type
but I said function
and I said then return the number of
lines the average for each type of file
return Nas you'll notice this prompt I'm
being much more explicit I'm getting
very detailed in what I want but I
really want people to focus on is that I
told it to get a line count of the
functions but since I said files so many
other times in the prompt it realized
that I misspoke and corrected for me
or I mistyped I should say and that's
really great that I realized my mistake
now it did give us oxygen automatically
for this function I left it out so it
would fit on the slide
now the function works this gives us the
average number of lines for each file
type whether you use the default case or
whether you specify what files you want
so I'm really excited about this
now I said now write a function that
uses this function to generate a bar
plot of the average number of lines of
each file type
so pretty cool right you'll see here
that it uses ggplot by default it just
knows that's what I wanted because
everyone uses ggplot
and it uses theme minimal because I
guess it knows the default plotting no
one likes it anymore so it went straight
for theme minimal it's still doing
package colon colon function even for GG
pop it's a little odd and when I said
use this function it knew I meant the
previous one not the previous previous
one and again it gave us oxygen but I
truncated it so it would fit
and here is our beautiful plot
looks really gorgeous right it's
actually well well designed good color
choices I did have to print it sometimes
with ggplot you need to print it
depending how it's designed I didn't
spend the time figuring that out I could
have
but then I asked for another step
I said modify the function to allow
users to choose either ggplot or
e-charts and then make whichever version
the user requests
so it uses an if statement to check do
you want ggplot here's Gigi plot
do you want a e-chart it uses e-charts
but notice here there is no package
called e-chart r
it doesn't exist
they use the wrong package name
so I had to correct it and said it looks
like you're trying to use e-chart r
instead of e charts 4r
so it actually apologized for its
mistake
and then rewrote the function
now the only problem is here I had to
know that e charts for R was the real
function maybe I could have asked that
hey that doesn't exist what's the right
name maybe you could have figured it out
but I gave it the right function name
and now I could set plot library to e
charts for R and this is an interactive
plot now you could hover over and double
click it and do all that cool stuff
so it's really really nice
but I don't like the if statement I
don't like that as using if statement to
switch back and forth so I said instead
of checking which plot libraries with an
if statement make the default argument a
vector of possible values then check
with match.org
and it did that you'll see that it uses
match.org to figure out which of the
available choices it used but it still
use the if statement it didn't actually
change this statement it just used
match.org to figure out what the user
input
so I'll come back to that later I'll fix
that later
then I said you know what instead of
putting all the code in the body of the
function break out the ggplot code and
the e-charts code to their own functions
then have a wrapper function to call
them
and it told me this is great for making
the code more modular and that's nice to
get the feedback
so you can see here before we saw the
individual functions this is the wrapper
function that does it and it still
figures out how to do it with an if
statement and I it's using match.org but
it's still using an if statement so I
gave it a very unhelpful prompt I said
almost got it but use match.r here too
now even though it was using mash.org it
realized I meant get rid of the if
statement
and you see it got rid of this statement
it made a list of it actually made a
list of plots it generated each of the
two plots and made a list of those
options and then with mash.org I figured
out which plot I wanted and subsetted
the list to give me back the plot
it's a little not awesome it's it's not
quite an error but it's not great and
we'll fix it in a little bit
but first I said add options for base R
and lattice
because I know that Jeff Ryan loves base
r
and I know that David Robinson hates
lattice
so I put it in there and I put them both
in there and I actually created new
functions and then we realized this they
realized that we already had this
General function and then individual
functions for the different libraries
and it did that for me
now when I make a base plot it prints
out some numbers and I didn't bother
looking into why I probably could figure
that out but I didn't bother but look
how much this still looks like the Gigi
plot
it looks almost as attractive
so you could actually do amazing stuff
with base plot it's just a lot harder
and I wouldn't want to write it myself
likewise I wouldn't want to write
lattice code but it wrote lattice code
for me that's awesome except notice here
notice there's two being printed on the
slide
that's felt wrong to me so I told chat
gbt it looks like you're printing both
and I realized and again I had to notice
this is that remember the list was
generating the plots in a list and then
subsetting it so instead it is now
storing a named list using the functions
as objects in the list and then it will
subset the list of functions to get one
function based on the mash.org and then
call that with parentheses around your
object
and that's great this is like a great
example of good R programming I love
this function now
and here is the fixed lattice plot
everything works we're happy so now I
say
I want to turn these functions into a
package can you outline the steps
the reason you do that is because
oftentimes it's great to have chat GPT
tell you what steps you need to do and
then feed those steps back into chat GPT
later
and it told me to install Dev tools use
devtools create copy the functions
document them build install other things
but first I said can you help me come up
with a name for the package
it came up with five options and gave
the reasons for the options
none were super awesome but they're all
camel case so I'm happy so I went with
it
and I said let's use file type analyzer
and it told me it's a great choice
it's like a nice affirmation and then
wish me luck
it's really sweet
so nice that can you help me fill out
the description field and it gave me
this nice description and it came up
with more than that it gave me actually
more than in the whole description file
and this is the entire description file
and it listed all the packages we need
or so I thought
and it listed a few extra packages as
well that I don't need
it got a little confused
so they said let's use the MIT license
and it gave me it gave me a new
description file and it gave me the MIT
license file and it told me to change
the year and the name for the file so
that's helpful but notice this don't
mind the typo where I misspelled license
but chat gbt was unfazed
so that's pretty great
here's a license file where it told me
to you know change the name and
everything
but then I went too vague I said can you
write tests for each of the functions
included in the package
and it told me how important it is
in hindsight what I would have done is I
would have taken one function one at a
time gave the function back to the
prompt and said please write a test for
this because it got confused
notice now it's using snake case instead
of camel case for both the function name
and the argument names
and the function name is wrong who knows
that the test is testing properly
likewise for my second function again
the names are snake case instead of
camel case and in searching this
directory which is supposed to do but
that directory doesn't necessarily exist
then for the plotting test all it did
and explain the problem it just tested
them to make sure it didn't give an
error
it would have been nice if it at least
tested for the class of the object
coming back you can test is this a Gigi
plot is this a lattice maybe you can't
do that for base R but you can do it for
E charts 4r so it would have been nice
if it came back of a test for classes
but you know not bad it gave me a lot of
stuff it gave me I forgot about expect
silent it reminded me
but then it also told me that I should
use from the test that package set up
and tear down in order to build that
test directory and set that up for me
I'm like awesome can you show me how to
use that how would I use it and it built
out how to set up like hey create
temporary files
then use your code test the code then
delete the files it did all that and it
did a pretty decent job explaining it
accept that
setup and tear down have been superseded
it can't keep up with the changes in the
Tidy verse
but not bad I asked it to populate data
into this test files it just created
blank files I asked it to populate data
and when it did that
it made all the files txt files when
before it was giving me txt and CSV and
Json
so it's getting a little confused at
this point because it's forgotten
everything that came earlier you also
notice the test isn't awesome we know
well I know at this point the function
returns a tibble but it's checking for a
data frame and also I happen to discover
in the tibble a column was like a named
Vector inside the column so like it
should have been using expect equivalent
instead of expect equal
and the test out of everything I was
doing that was like the most wrong part
but it's probably because it came last I
didn't re-feed it information
then I asked it a question like do I do
setup and tear down once for the entire
package do I do it for each of the
individual test files and it told me for
the individual test files
all right so things are okay
then I said for the plotting functions
can you use a visual differ
and I only knew to ask this because I
used this before if you didn't know a
visual differ existed you wouldn't know
what to do here but I asked for it and
it used V Devar
now of course it's still using the wrong
function names and it's actually at this
point not only using the wrong function
names it's calling it incorrectly
it's passing in a data frame instead of
a path
but you know it's my fault I should have
fed it the fought tests I'm taking the
blame for the machine now so Stockholm
Syndrome
but
after I highly modified the test and I
made a lot of changes all the tests pass
including the visual differs so that's
really awesome
then I did a full cram check I said
let's check it and this is where things
start going even more sideways
I get a bunch of notes about non-visible
bindings which everyone loves dealing
with that
I forgot to import the tibble package
and it didn't export the migrator pipe
or import the magritta package
and it imported packages we didn't need
so I had to manually fix all that both
in the description file and in the
oxygen files I fixed it I did some help
work to fix it out so now it's ready to
publish
so I asked it to draft a tweet to
announce the package
it even used an emoji
it knows how much the r Community loves
it and it suggested that I use a hex
sticker
because it knows that the r Community
loves heck stickers right
so how am I going to make the hex
thicker well now I turn to Dolly
and I say a calculator superimposed over
a stack of papers in the style of Andy
Warhol
not bad right
it came out like this and the trick I
learned the first few times I prompted
it I asked for a hex sticker of a
calculator superimposed over a stack of
paper it just went horribly
I realized okay just get a rectangular
image and then I can crop it
okay but how do I crop it
how do I convert this image into a hex
sticker and it told me to use the heck
sticker package
now I had to change some of the settings
from the default that chat GPT suggested
but still it suggested all these
settings like the different values but
it got me there and it looks like this
yes I know the packaging looks terrible
that's human error right
I could have made that nicer I could
have chose a different instead of green
I could have chose something else but
it's great so all I have to do now is
send this image to Sticker Mule and
they'll send you back your heck stickers
they cut it out for you it's great
so I'm very happy with this so what do
we learn through all that stuff right
now
well the llm can write decent functions
quickly
they're not great functions but they're
good and they're fast
it made a bunch of mistakes that I
needed to catch
but that's okay because I make mistakes
that I need to catch
so we all deal with that
it definitely needs guidance on style
like stick to snake case or stick to
camel case use package colon colon
function
and in these directions on less often
used tools like V diff R and I even
rarely use that so it needs a little bit
of direction on these tools
and it gets confused as you go further
along so that's why remember I actually
mentioned you need to ask for the steps
and give it back the steps you need to
actually give it back the stuff as you
go to remind it which happens to humans
too
and it needs a human checking the work
or you need to at least tell it to check
itself
so you know this isn't something that
can go alone right now you need some you
need some help
and if you want to use the package it's
on GitHub
I haven't put it on crayon because it's
honestly not that useful but it's up
there now I did need to make a lot of
modifications I needed to fix some
things but it's working it's up there it
passes the test it passes the checks
it's up there
and if you want to get a transcription
of the chat that I had at chat GPT you
can go to this link the slides will be
available and you can click that and see
my entire chat and everything it did
so that's really fun way to it's really
great you can go and see what's going on
so thank you very much
foreign